[Musique]
incontournable du petit déjeuner des
Britanniques la marmelade est aussi très
présente sur les tablettes de nos
épiceries et dans nos réfrigérateurs
voyons aujourd'hui si les gens qui
fréquentent ce pavillon de l'UQAM on
l'habitude de consommer cette gelée
originaire du Portugal mais faites la
plupart du temps avec des oranges de CBI
pour le savoir on teste 4 produits la
marmelade double fruit Choix du
Président bonne maman et saint Dalfour
place à la dégustation
mangez-vous de la marmelade sur vos
reptils le matin moi non en général ça a
l'air bon alors on va découvrir ensemble
quatre marmelade je vous laisse goûter
puis vous me dites lequel vous préférez
ces quatre compagnies différentes
[Rires]
celle qu'on connaît c'est à base
d'agrumes donc à base d'orange
principalement la marmelade c'est comme
une confiture mais plus sucrée dont la
texture est différente l'ingrédient
principal est souvent le sucre ensuite
il devait avoir dans un produit que vous
achetez l'agrément complet donc le zest
qui cuit longtemps dans le sucre qui
fait une texture intéressante
il y a ici l'écorce blanc qui fait la
pectine naturelle du fruit et bien sûr
le jus du fruit
[Musique]
ça ça veut dire oui
celui-là il y a beaucoup de produits
ajoutés c'est vraiment un produit qui a
été cuit moins longtemps donc il ajoute
beaucoup de produits on voit que les
morceaux sont là au complet
[Musique]
le fruit de l'orange aussi donc c'est
pour ça qu'il y a un petit côté assez
dur
tu as préféré
[Rires]
[Musique]
si on trouve vraiment des morceaux de
fruits vraiment plus épaisses
on trouve vraiment toute le morceau de
fond on voit bien écorce ici au complet
donc ça cuit longtemps dans le sucre ce
qui va donner la consistance en
mélangeant avec la personne c'est
vraiment l'équilibre qui fait la
consistance
[Musique]
un petit peu moins naturel mais c'est en
général les marmelas c'est sucré donc
ici on trouve une marmelade qui est
vraiment plus liquide il y a pas tout la
grume à l'intérieur on trouve le zest on
voit des beaux morceaux de zeste bien
effilées mais on voit que c'est beaucoup
plus liquide que normalement
je l'aime bien mais je trouve un peu
trop amer à mon goût et toi
j'aime bien après
c'est moins agréable à manger parce que
il y a un petit arrière-goût qui enlève
un peu le goût du fruit en lui-même
il y a un peu de citron ici j'ai
l'impression
[Musique]
et j'ai senti ici la peau du citron
comme je ne sais pas si on écorce
la texture est intéressante on voit bien
les morceaux de fruits les morceaux de
décors on voit le zeste aussi
ça se tient j'ai un goût plus de la
pulpe autour de
l'orange c'est un peu acide mais je
trouve que c'est un bon équilibre salut
c'est ta bonne c'est juste que la
texture m'intéresse moins ça c'est plus
crémeux
on n'est pas très surprise la marmelade
est pas nécessairement très populaire
chez nos buteurs et nos bouteilles on se
rend compte c'est peut-être une question
de génération nos maires nos
grands-mères surtout consommés de la
marmelade mon objectif qui est aimé ça
surtout c'est qu'ils sont sucrées
de la moitié on choisit la marmelade
double fruit comme leur préférée
peut-être que ça va vous donner envie
d'y goûter
[Musique]